ask him to shoot more to extend his
range you got to be a threat from all
areas on the floor and he's done that
Harry's gorgeous stroke you shoot a shot
straight on like that you're not
shooting from Fat Boy Paris fires three
extended possession three he could not
buy one tonight looking for levert
scream Lebert dribble-drive harris
catching fire hits a three
47 seconds left answer down by seven
have to work quickly here levert
stumbles Paris fires
10x it's a three Aris instead it's
Russell who takes a peek of the clock
with six Russell makes his move
no look Paris corner Jay bottom it rims
in for three draws the defense he's
looking he keeps his eyes focused on Joe
Joe comes down and knocks down the three
five minutes to play first half Paris
faked hook it it's three beautiful job
by Joe Harris this is a good matchup and
then they go small man-to-man
Russell kicks Harris
Russell finding Harris nice try nice
room release and rhythm oh no that's not
what I was saying
20-point lead for broken weapon Paris
that's a three and the three point party
continues we've talked about their
prowess in the third quarter this season
Harris he's got it it's a three
Jen woody - Harris 3 on the way
a chance at a four-point play by Joe
Harris you see how quickly he comes off
of this Eddie Davis screen allows him
just enough space CJ Miles closing in on
or get away it's a big question
[Applause]
Harris cans the three looks inside Allen
finds Harris
[Applause]
Paris delivers punic oranges play for
Brooklyn
I'm just waiting gets a big block and
then catch and shoot by Joe Harris
Dinwiddie
explodes through the lane good movement
Harris
nice touch to finish that over top of
rondae hollis-jefferson Joe Harris gets
a three it's well here in the third
quarter important that the Nets she
could do what they did then just rebound
by committee
it goes away yeah something hearing
extracting it three seconds Paris fire
Joe Harris beats the clock the clock but
you watch the Nets band [ __ ] it turns
up the band the way they're all dancing
open it here we go Dinwiddie step back
off the back of the iron Harris keeps it
alive for juggling ball movement Harris
Joe Harris
chi'lan it from the corner here's that
longshot
where is Harris right there a beautiful
back tap and look at his feet he gets it
he's called to the ball the quarter and
he just flat-out drills us 12 to shoot
and looking for the three here it comes
[Music]
and look at him come up he gets a great
screen by hollis-jefferson and nobody
reacts that was monk who is a second
late Paris
[Applause]
[Applause]
was coming out there giving some more
effort and allowing them to transition
parish were the three should go up by ET
and splits defenders he's bodying with
DeAngelo Russell parish lets it fly it
he got fouled a three goes down at a
four point play opportunity here
Oh Harris he made sure to turn to burn
icky and let him know that that shot
went in and the foul Russell Harris at
three good for Joe Harris as it changes
what you do offensively
that's drill eight for Harrison cut into
it and does with a triple
step through dishes gotta shoot it Paris
does
Joe e buckets a three it's down to
parish lines it up and knocks it down
from three what a big shout out 12 times
that's it and four bats
hits another jolting Joe to the rescue
trying to use that hand on the bat as
like a bar but look at Joe back-to-back
decks trying to bring the lead to double
digits Harris over yogi
[Applause]
womper Joe so he doesn't get it blocked
that Joe recognizes that this big guy is
just not going to get out here Lyle's
now with 12 points for Dedrick 38
seconds to go
[Applause]
focus to the side as we see Joe Harris
come up get rhythm with a nice lift to
the jump shot Russell and Lowry pumping
bodies eight to shoot outside Harris
[Applause]
is a machine conscience from the outside
Paris of the Nets leading at halftime
oh wow that'll make you really things at
the Angela boxer shot Joe Harris deficit
like the nets are that's what you want
to match earth Anna control grabbed it
back Harris of three and it's good for
Joe Harris two minutes to go
Russell up board for Brooklyn down by 13
hairs going to try another one and gets
it to go
you know when he and Jason Tatum were
recruited to Duke Giles was actually the
more highly recruited guy as Harris hits
the three ending the run
Harris moving left ball Connaughton
trying to stick with it Harris do a lot
of work
[Applause]
kuu roots is one of seven from
three-point range Harris he let split so
go by and drains it there's a really
good adjustment by the throw
Middleton loses the ball Harris jars it
out of there and here comes Russel
swings it Harris spots up the chain yes
Joe Harris money thing gets it ahead
find the shooter and Joe Harris yep you
got it that's buckets this is the
matchup he wants Russell goes around
Lopez no floater back in the iron back
tap Laberge got it Harris fires Joe
Harris he can't sit the middle of the
paint
he's got the mismatch against Brook
Lopez bucks waiting at him because so
many players are in the page it was an
excellent tip extra tip out by Jared
Dudley
the pass by Graham get into a half-court
set here backdoor levert extra fee
extra extra Paras bleed all about it
it's a three type of pursuit that they
stay anytime a shot goes up and then
once again here's Joe Harris he's coming
around there's nothing there
Karis labert backdoor all the way around
the horn he get it to the best shooter
in the NBA Joe Curtis in replacing
Russell Coutts getting ready to check in
liver drawers defenders ball movement
Joe Harris he nails it Paris from deep
for Center above 20% this year the three
so try again that's the play what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content